Jamal you have played for Doc Rivers um
first your take on making this decision
now and the possible changes that we've
heard I don't like it to be honest with
you just the fact that he he he
interviewed for 14 different coaching
jobs he gets one they have a better
record than they did this year this
point last year and let's be honest the
Bucs aren't going to be judged on the
regular season anyway this is a team
they're trying to go to the finals
they're going to be judged on their
postseason success he didn't get a
chance at that and for me that's
disheartening because he took so long to
get this opportunity he gets it he does
well with it they're not they have the
third best record in the league period
and for him to get fired I don't like
that part of it Candace I think the only
thing that was confusing to me was when
Chris reported that they hired him not
thinking that they had Championship
aspirations when you have Giannis saent
kmo who is top three in the
league how do you not have Championship
aspirations and so I think
that Adrien was hired at a disadvantage
we're not in the locker room on a dayto
day the buyin is super important
especially from your star players
defensively yes there is going to be a
shift you lost Drew holiday who is one
of the best oneon-one defenders in this
league you can switch abilities
Championship just a great guy there's
going to take time for an adjustment
with Dame and Giannis um but here's what
I will say with this coaching change
this makes me think that that the Bucks
aren't done like there's going to be a
lot of movement I think at trade
deadline player Perhaps Perhaps a
dejonte Murray perhaps someone like that
that's going to be able to come in
and play and kind of add to the coaching
change as well so I I think this is very
interesting I think the thing that
sticks out is that they didn't have
Championship aspirations right that to
me was was very telling sha there have
been other stories that have come out
like via the athletic where they said
said during the inseason tournament Doc
Rivers was actually brought in to be an
advisor to Adrien Griffin as you hear
all this news how do you process you
know we we've all excuse me we've all
been around the business of basketball a
long time something else is going on
last time something like this happened
David blat 1311 Tylo took over and win
the championship Chris used the the term
save the season and when you say save
the season I would think there would be
11 and 37 third best record in the
league second best record in the East
new players new coaching staff you know
I've I've always been the firm believer
that coach okay we as players got to do
it you know we talk about defense and
numbers you have to want to play defense
and that's why I always talked about
timely stops I'm I'm not a def I'm not
want to play defense CU I'm big I'm
getting lot of trouble but two minutes
left we got to get timely stops and you
know the these guys are are young
they're working together but I think
something else is going on on I don't
want to speculate I don't know what's
going on but you know you talk about a
guy like Doc Rivers yes he's an
experienced coach but he only has one
Championship uh you know you talk about
Jeff F Gundy he has a lot of experience
but again when it comes to the players
don't care what schemes you have you
have to want to play defense and Dame is
not known as a defensive player but
again that's why I always try to stick
up for these guys and say hey if you can
have timely stops because they have
enough talent to you know they got they
got major Firepower offensively but you
know in these close games the last two
minutes you have to say okay I'm I'm I'm
shutting this guy down and until the
players take onus and say that doesn't
matter who they're going to bring in
they're still going to have these up and
downs but their ups and downs are really
good ups and down like they're they
sicking in East like I don't understand
what the problem is but I think being
around this business for a long time
something else is going on so we'll just
stay tuned you know see what's going on
and for Adrien Griffin I think those of
us that know him know he is a great guy
and he has now a care record of 30 and
13 so that will look good I'm sure he'll
get another
chance